well because you brought up Joe he's
somebody like you I look up to
uh I've learned a lot from him because I
think
who he is privately as a human being
also his he's kind of the voice of
curiosity to me
he inspired me that's an unending
open-minded curiosity
um much like you are the voice of reason
uh they recently had a podcast Joe had
written a podcast of Jordan Peterson and
he uh brought you up saying they still
have a hope for you yeah uh any chance
any chance you talk to Joe again and
reinvigorate your friendship
yet why I reached out to him privately
when I saw that did you use the power of
love
Joe knows I love him and consider him a
friend right so there's no there's no
issue there
um he also knows I'll I'll be happy to
do his podcast uh
when we get that together you know so
there's no I've got no policy of not
talking to Joe or not doing his podcast
um
I mean I think we're we got a little
sideways along these same lines where
you know we've talked about Brett and
Elon and other people
um it was never
to that degree with Joe because
um
Joe's in a very different Lane right
he's unconsciously so I mean Joe is a
stand-up comic who interviews who just
is interested in it in everything
interviews the widest conceivable
variety of people
and just lets his interests collide with
their expertise or you know lack of
expertise I mean he's again it's a super
wide variety of people
um he'll talk about anything and he can
always pull the rip cord saying
you know I don't know what the [__] I'm
saying I'm a comic I'm stoned we just
drank too much right like like it's very
entertaining it's all in you know to my
eye it's it's all in good faith I think
Joe is an extraordinarily ethical good
person also doesn't use Twitter doesn't
really use it yeah yeah no The crucial
difference though is it because he
is
an Entertainer first I mean I'm not
saying he's not smart and doesn't
understand things he I mean what's confu
potentially confusing he's very smart
and he he's also very informed he's he
his full-time job is taught you know
when he's not doing stand-up we're doing
color commentary for the UFC
his full-time job is talking to lots of
very smart people at Great length so
he's he's created a you know the Joe
Rogan University for himself and he's
gotten a lot of information uh crammed
into his head so it's not that he's
uninformed but he can always when he
feels that he's uninformed or when it
turns out he was wrong about something
he can always pull the rip cord and say
I I'm just a comic we were stoned it was
fun you know don't don't take medical
advice from me I don't play a doctor on
the internet right
um
I can't quite do that right you can't
quite do that we're in different Lanes
I'm not saying you you and I are in
exactly the same Lane but for much of
Joe's audience I'm just this
establishment shill who's just banging
on about you know the universities and
medical journals and and
um it's not true but that would be the
perception and as a Counterpoint to a
lot of what's being said on Joe's
podcast or or uh you know certainly
Brett's podcast on these topics I can
see how they they would form that
opinion but
in reality if you listen to me long
enough you hear that
I've said as much against the woke
nonsense as anyone even any lunatic on
the right who's can only keep that
bright that bright shiny object in view
right
um so there's nothing that Candace Owens
has said about wokeness that I haven't
said about wokeness as far insofar as
she's speaking rationally about wokeness
um
but
we have to be able to keep multiple
things in view right if you if you could
only look at the problem of wokeness and
you couldn't acknowledge the problem of
trump and trumpism and Q Anon and and
the explosion of irrationality that was
happening on the right and bigotry that
was happening on the right
um you just you were you were just
disregarding half of the landscape and
many people took half of the problem
in the in recent years in the last five
years is a story of many people taking
half of the problem and monetizing that
half of the problem and and getting
captured by an audience that only wanted
that half of the problem talked about in
that way and um
and this is the larger issue of of uh
audience capture which you know is very
I'm sure it's
it's an ancient problem but um it's a
very helpful phrase that I think comes
to us courtesy of our mutual friend Eric
Weinstein and
audience captures a thing and I believe
I've witnessed many you know casualties
of it and if there's anything I've been
on guard against in my life you know
professionally it's been that and and
when I noticed that I had a lot of
people in my audience
who didn't like my criticizing Trump
I really leaned into it and when I
noticed that a lot of the other cohort
in my honest didn't like me criticizing
the far left and wokeness I thought I
was you know exaggerating that problem I
leaned into it because I thought those
parts of my audience were were
absolutely wrong and I didn't care about
whether I was going to lose those parts
of my audience there are people who have
created you know
knowingly or not there are people who've
created different incentives for
themselves because how they they've
monetized their podcast and because of
the kind of signal they've responded to
In Their audience
um and I worry about you know I know
Brett would consider this a totally
invidious
uh ad hominem thing to say but I really
do worry that that's happened to Brett I
think I think I I cannot explain how you
do a hundred with all the things in the
in the universe to be interested in and
of all the things he's competent to
speak intelligently about I don't know
how you do a hundred podcasts in a row
on on covet right it's just it makes no
sense you think um in part audience
capture can explain that I absolutely
think it can yeah what about
do you like for example do you feel
pressure to not admit that you made a
mistake on covet or made a mistake on
Trump
I'm not saying you feel that way but do
you feel this pressure so you've
attacked audience capture within
yourself within the way you do stuff so
you don't feel as much pressure from the
audience but within your own ego
I mean again the people who think I'm
wrong about any of these topics are
going to think okay you're just
not admitting that you're wrong but then
now we're having a dispute about
specific facts
um
there are there are things that I
believed about covet or worried might
very might be true about covet two years
ago that I no longer believe or I'm not
so worried about now and and vice versa
I mean like the things are flipped
certain things are flipped upside down
um
the question is was I wrong so here's a
here's the cartoon version of it but
this is something I said probably 18
months ago and it's still true
you know when I saw what Brett was doing
on covid you know
let's call it two years ago
I I said even if he is right even if he
turned if even turns out that Ivermectin
is a Panacea and the MRNA vaccines kill
millions of people right he's still
wrong right now his reasoning is still
flawed right now his facts still suck
right now right and his and his
confidence is is unjustified now that
was true then that will always be true
then right and and so
and not much has changed for me to to
revisit any of my time points along the
way again I will totally concede that if
I had teenage boys and their Dot and
their schools were demanding that they'd
be vaccinated with the MRNA vaccine
I would I would be powerfully annoyed
right I like I would I wouldn't know
what I was going to do and I would be I
would be doing more research about about
myocarditis and I'd be badgering our
doctors and I would be worried that we
have a medical system and a
pharmaceutical system and a Health Care
system and a public health system that's
not incentivized to to look at any of
this in a fine-grained way and they just
want one uh blanket admonition to the
entire population just get just take the
shot you idiots
uh I view that largely as a result a
panicked response to the misinformation
explosion that happened and the public
the populist resistance animated but
misinformation that just made it
impossible to get anyone to to cooperate
right so it was just part of it is again
a pendulum swing in the wrong direction
if someone analogous to the woke
responds to Trump and the trumpist
response to woke right so this is a lot
of people have just gotten pushed around
for bad reasons or but understandable
reasons but
yes
it's there are there are caveats to my
things have changed about my view of
covet but the question is if you roll
back the clock 18 months was I wrong to
want to platform
uh Eric topel you know a a very well
respected cardiologist on this topic or
you know Nicholas christakis to to talk
about the network effects of you know
the you know whether we should close
schools right he's written a book on
covid he's you know Network effects or
his wheelhouse as it both as an MD and
as a sociologist
um
there was a lot that we believed we knew
about the efficacy of of closing schools
during pandemics right during the you
know during the
the Spanish Flu pandemic and others
right but there's a lot we didn't know
about covet we didn't know we didn't
know how
uh
negligible the effects would be on kids
compared to older people we didn't know
it like so my problem I really enjoyed
your conversation with octopo but also
didn't
so he is one of the Great communicators
in many ways on Twitter like
distillation of the current data but he
I hope I'm not overstating it but
there is a bit of an arrogance
from him that I think it could be
explained by him being exhausted by
being constantly attacked by conspiracy
theory like anti-vaxxers yeah
to me the same thing happens with people
that start drifting to be being right
wing
is to get attacked so much by the left
they become almost irrational and
arrogant in their beliefs and I I felt
your conversation with Eric Topo did not
sufficiently empathize with people that
have skepticism but also did not
sufficiently communicate uncertainty we
have so like many of the decisions you
made many of the things you were talking
about
we're kind of saying there's a lot of
uncertainty but this is the best thing
we can do now well it was a forest
Choice you're going to get covid do you
want to be vaccinated when you get it
right that was always
in my view an easy choice
and it's up until you you start breaking
apart the cohorts and you start saying
okay wait a minute there is this
myocarditis issue in in young men let's
talk about that
when that's before that story emerged it
was just it was just clear that
this is
if it's not if it's not knocking down
transmission as much as we had hoped it
is still mitigating severe illness and
death
uh and
I I still believe that it is the the
current view of the of
most people competent to analyze the
data that we lost something like 300 000
people unnecessarily in the US because
of because of vaccine hesitancy but I
think there's a way to communicate with
humility about the uncertainty of things
that would increase the vaccination rate
I do believe that it is
rational and sometimes effective
to to Signal impatience with certain
bad ideas right and certain conspiracy
theories and certain forms of
misinformation so
because it's just I just think it makes
you look good douchebag most times well
I mean certain people are persuadable
certain people are not not persuadable
but
it's um no because there's not enough
it's the opportunity cost not everything
can be given a patient hearing it's like
you can't have a physics conference
and then let people in to just Trump at
their pet theories about you know the
grand unified vision of physics
um when they're obviously crazy or
they're obviously half crazy or they're
just not you know the the people like
you begin to you begin to get a sense
for this it when it is your wheelhouse
but there are people who
kind of declare their their
irrelevance to the conversation fairly
quickly without knowing that they have
done it right and uh
and the truth is I think I'm one of
those people on the topic of covet right
like I it's like it's not it's never
that I felt listen
I know exactly what's going on here I
know these mRNA vaccines are safe I know
exactly I know I know exactly how to run
a lockdown I
no this is this is a situation where you
want the actual Pilots to fly the plane
right we needed experts who we could
trust and insofar as our experts got
captured by by all manner of thing I
mean some of them got captured by Trump
some of them were made to look
ridiculous just standing next to Trump
while he was bloviating about you know
whatever that you know that it's just
going to go away there's just 15 people
you know there's 15 people in a cruise
ship and it's just going to go away
there's going to be no problem or it's
like when he said he you know many of
these doctors think I understand this
better than them they're just amazed at
how I understand this and you've got
doctors real doctors the heads of the
CDC and and NIH standing around just
ashen-faced while he's talking you know
um all of this was deeply corrupted of
the Public Communication of science on
both and then again I've banged on about
the depredations of wokeness the woke
thing was a disaster or it still is a
disaster
but it doesn't mean
that I mean but the thing is there's a
big difference between me and Brett in
this case I didn't do 100 podcasts on
covid I did like two podcasts on covet
through the measure of my concern about
covid can be measured in how many
podcasts I did on it right it's like
once we had a sense of how to live with
covid
I was just living with covet right like
okay if you get vacs or don't get vaxxed
wear a mask or don't wear a mask travel
or don't travel like you've got a few
things to decide but
my kids were stuck at home on iPads you
know for too long I didn't agree with
that it was obviously not functional
like I criticized that on the margins
but there was not much to do about it
but the the thing I didn't do is make
this my life and just browbeat people
with one message or another
we need a public health regime
where we can trust what the competent
people are saying to us about you know
what medicines are safe to take and in
the absence of that
craziness is going to even in the
presence of that craziness is going to
proliferate given the tools we've built
but in the absence of that it's going to
proliferate for understandable reasons
and that's gonna
that's it's not going to be good next
time when when something orders of
magnitude more dangerous hits us and
that and that's
I spent you know insofar as I think
about this issue I think much more about
next time than this time